[APPLAUSE]
MAYSOON ZAYID: Hello, Google.
My name-- OK, they
wanted to respond,
so we'll do it that way.
OK.
So, hello, Google.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
MAYSOON ZAYID: My
name is Maysoon Zayid.
And the day I was
born, I almost died.
I came out fist first,
ready to fight the power.
Unfortunately, the
doctor who delivered me
was not ready for this jelly.
He cut my mom six
different times,
in six different directions.
The first cut gave
me my first breath.
And then the dear
old doc smothered me.
So I have brain damage.
Aren't you jealous?
I have what is called
cerebral palsy.
And cerebral palsy
is a spectrum,
and the symptoms are
totally different,
depending on the person with CP.
In my case, I
shake all the time.
So I shake it, shake it,
shake it, like Taylor Swift.
Except she just wants
to shake, shake, shake,
and mine is totally involuntary.
OK, Google?
This is comedy.
Come on a journey with me.
At some point, every
single one of you
has dreamt of being disabled.
It's Christmas Eve.
You're at the mall.
You're driving around,
looking for parking,
and what do you see?
16 empty handicap spaces.
You're like, god, can't
I be a little disabled?
Just, like, dyslexic
or something?
So I grew up in Cliffside
Park, New Jersey, which
makes me bridge-and-tunnel.
And I grew up in a time
where I was completely
oblivious to the fact that being
Muslim, Palestinian, brown,
a girl, and someone
with a disability
would be something
that in the future
would be used against me.
I had no idea that being
an other was a bad thing.
I grew up in an
extremely diverse town
with 33,000 Italian
Catholics and six Arabs that
were all my family.
And I don't think
anyone ever noticed
that I wasn't one of them.
Because look at me.
I look like the lost Kardashian.
People can't just guess.
But when I grew up, I
encountered something
that I was never prepared for.
Because as a child,
I was never bullied.
I was never mocked.
When I was growing
up, "Muslim" wasn't
a slur used by
candidates and campaigns
to gain the hate vote.
It was just-- Maysoon doesn't
eat for a whole month.
And she doesn't
lose a single pound.
It's fascinating.
But then I
encountered something.
I encountered social media,
and my entire world changed.
I started my dalliance
with social media
back in the days of chat rooms.
And no, it's not the chat
rooms that you think.
I only frequented one chat
room-- the "Soap Opera Digest"
chat room.
I would spend hours a day
discussing a soap opera
that I had watched since
I was five years old.
Because even though I
was born to extremely
strict Palestinian
Muslim parents,
my parents had no idea that
they should monitor what
I watched on TV.
So I was all about love in the
daytime and Andrew Dice Clay.
These are the
things that I loved.
So I started off
in the chat rooms.
It was nice.
Everything was great.
I had AOL dial-up.
You had to put the
CD-- computers used
to have these CD-ROMs.
You know, because I'm
like 150 in Google years.
I walked around this
building and did not
see a single old person.
I think that you guys
put them to sleep at 40.
And then wake them
up again at 100,
because Google's nefarious,
and you can do that.
So my next thing,
though, was Facebook.
And I was sitting in a room
with one of my bridesmaids.
I've been a bridesmaid
17 times, and I've
spent $28,000 on my
friends' weddings.
So when I turned 33, I decided
to get married, because I
wanted to make my money back.
And because also, like,
married people, they
sucker you into marriage, and
they don't explain anything
about it.
So they dress like
a Michelin man.
It looks like it's all fun.
They get all these gifts.
And they don't tell you that
it's a 50-year commitment.
They're just like,
yay, I went to Belize.
So at 33, I decided
to get married,
because I wanted to
make my money back.
And I went to catch a husband.
Now, let me be clear about this.
People seem to think that
people with disabilities
don't, like, date.
They think we're these eternal
snowflake angel babies that
are, like, ahh, I'm so happy.
And that's totally not true.
We do date.
And I wasn't desperate
when I got married.
If my dad had allowed
me to marry someone
who wasn't Palestinian,
I could have
married this guy named Mike.
But my dad said that he would
throw himself off the George
Washington Bridge,
and I couldn't
bear the image of them fishing
him out, all bloated and shit.
So I had to catch a husband.
And the way my parents
met is really, really,
really romantic.
It's definitely something--
it's such a beautiful story.
And I think that
when people think
of Muslim or Arab
or Palestinian,
they don't think of romance.
But the way my parents
met is so beautiful.
They're first cousins.
My dad swears that the very
first time he saw my mom,
he knew she was the one.
And I was like, Daddy, how
did you know she was the one?
And he said, your
grandfather, he told me.
But I couldn't do what
my parents did, because I
am way too disabled to inbreed.
And I couldn't go on match.com,
because typing is not my thing.
So I was like, where am I
going to catch a husband?
Do you guys want to
know where I caught him?
I'm like a seal.
I won't do anything if
you don't clap and scream.
You want to know
where I caught him?
I went to Gaza.
And the reason I went
to Gaza is because they
got no place to run.
So here's what I did.
I took my American
passport and I framed it
in a big gold frame.
And I just walked through
the refugee camp, going,
you want a visa, baby?
And my husband was like, yes.
I'm like, pack up your stuff.
Let's go.
And he's like, I have no stuff.
So this is another time that
the internet came into my life
really strongly.
Because all of my friends
had these amazing proposals.
Like my friend Janet, she was
like, so he wrote "I love you"
on the Scrabble board.
And then we went up in
the hot air balloon.
The balloon exploded,
and the smoke
wrote, "Will you marry me?"
And as we were
plummeting to our deaths,
parachutes opened, and he slid
a Tiffany diamond on my hand.
And I'm like, I don't have the
coordination for any of that.
Like, none of it.
So I bought a diamond ring and
I gave it to him, because he
was a starving refugee.
Where's he gonna get
a diamond from, right?
And I showed him a
clip of the season
finale of "The Bachelorette."
And I'm like, this
is how you propose,
but you don't leave
two weeks later.
And you have to surprise me.
And then I waited.
One week, two
weeks, three weeks.
And I was like, aw,
man, he stole the ring.
And I was like, probably
needs to feed his family.
It's OK.
And then I was
crossing a checkpoint,
and I see him on the
other side, like this.
And I'm like, oh my god.
Now they're going to
shoot him, and I'm never
gonna get that ring.
Like what am I gonna
do, just loot the body?
Excuse me, it's mine.
So then he held out
the ring, and like
everything disappeared.
And he looked at me,
and I looked at him,
and he went, here!
Take it!
And I went, yes!
He speaks English.
So as I said, I was
never bullied as a child.
I was never made fun of.
And I happen to have the
exact same best friends
that I had when I was five
years old, the Jersey girls.
And yeah.
And my friends totally treated
me as an equal at all times.
So when I turned 21, I became
everyone's designated driver.
And the reason they did this
was because Muslims don't drink.
Or at least we don't admit
to it on social media.
So they were like, oh, perfect.
You know, Maysoon can be
the designated driver,
'cause she doesn't
want to go to hell.
And it's great.
And remember, no bacon.
And then-- but it
was a horrible idea.
Because law enforcement
is actually not
trained to deal with people
with disabilities, right?
And I thought about this a lot
during "Hands up, don't shoot,"
because my hands don't go up.
They just stop right here.
And when I used to
get pulled over--
because I'm a speed demon.
When I used to get pulled over,
the cop would come to the car,
and I would go to
hand him my license.
I'd be like, hey!
And he'd be like, are you drunk?
I'd be like, I'm not drunk.
I'm differently abled.
And then he would
ask my best friend
Tina, who was sitting
next to me, like slumped,
with vomit in her hair.
And they'd be
like, is she drunk?
And I will never, ever forget
the first time this happened.
The officer asked
her, is she drunk?
And Tina said, no,
she's retarded.
And I was like, oh my god,
where do I even begin with you?
And the thing is, my friend
Tina never caught on.
It's fascinating to
me that she thought
I had Down syndrome didn't
realize that retard was a slur,
and had been my best
friend since I was five.
And then I remembered,
Tina doesn't catch on.
My friend spent every single
summer at the Jersey Shore,
and my dad would send us back
to Palestine, to the war.
Because he was convinced that
if we didn't go to the Middle
East every single summer,
we would forget our heritage
and grow up to be
Britney Spears.
And every single year when I
went, she would come up to me
and ask the same question.
Are you scared?
Are you scared to
go to Pakistan?
So after Tina responds
to the police officer,
then he looked at me,
and he said, ma'am,
I'm gonna need you to
walk a straight line.
And I was like, I can't!
And I was like, can I just
do the alphabet backwards?
Z, Y, X, W, V. And he was like,
I can't even do it forward.
Go.
But like I said, I had the
same friends my entire life.
And so when I joined
Facebook, my Facebook friends
were my actual friends.
And I had no idea
what I was doing.
So my first status
was, I am on Facebook.
And I was so disappointed
because, I researched it
for this talk, and
I thought it would
be something like really deep.
And I was like, oh my god, I
just said, I am on Facebook.
So Facebook, I had
actual friends.
And then I joined Twitter.
And on Twitter,
I met the trolls.
And I've been a
comedian for 15 years.
And I grew up in a
time before YouTube.
So I actually had to
go to comedy clubs,
and stand and wait my turn.
And if you didn't bring
five people to watch you,
you weren't allowed
to get on stage.
And it was like a brutal game.
And my very first
job as a comedian
was driving famous
New York comics
from New York to New Jersey
to do shows in Atlantic City.
And I would be speeding
down the turnpike,
and they would be terrified.
Because I'd be like, no,
I'm an excellent driver.
I swear to God.
And then I'd whip into
the handicap space,
and they would
forget their fear.
They were like, yeah.
Yeah, she's good.
And so I had had to deal
with hecklers my whole life.
So internet trolls were
no big deal for me.
I thought it was fun.
Like, I basically
have a strategy
for my internet trolls.
First, I try to educate.
And what I mean by that is I
have some really well-meaning
trolls.
They just want to help me.
They just want to save me.
So in 2013, I did this TED Talk.
Now, prior to that,
I was actually
known as the Arab J-Lo.
I kid you not.
This is very funny.
I was a comedian, and I had gone
on "Arabs Gone Wild" and "Allah
Made Me Funny."
And I did-- I shot a documentary
called "The Muslims Are
Coming," where this guy who was
my partner, Dean Obeidallah,
he came up with this
brilliant idea for a bunch
of Muslim comics to tour
places in the deep South that
had, like, set mosques on
fire and I peed on Qurans.
So we went, in August,
during Ramadan,
to shoot a documentary
in Alabama, Mississippi,
Gainesville, Florida,
Columbus, Georgia.
I mean, Tupelo, Mississippi.
And I was fasting
the entire time
that we were on tour,
which really gave me
patience for bigotry.
It's amazing, when you're
hangry, how much patience you
have for these people.
But even worse than
that was my producer.
And my producer came up to me
one day and she said, listen,
we can't stop after the
show for you to eat.
Because the shows were
always during the time
that I was supposed
to break my fast.
She said, we have to
get to the next city.
So can you just grab like
a bagel or something?
And I was like,
no, I can't survive
on a bagel for
the next 24 hours.
And the producer looked
at me, and she said,
Maysoon, nobody
told you to fast.
And I said, nobody told you to
do a documentary about Muslims
during Ramadan and expect
no one to be fasting!
So I was known as the Arab J-Lo.
And then I did this TED Talk.
And when I did my TED Talk,
I called it "99 Problems,
and Palsy is Just One."
And the point was get
Beyonce's attention.
That's actually the only point.
No.
The point was to
say that we are more
than just our disabilities.
And I did this entire talk about
how people with disabilities
are the largest
minority in the world,
and we're the most
under-represented
on television.
And when we are
represented, it's
usually by able-bodied
actors cripping up.
And the disabled community
finds that really offensive.
We believe that much like race,
physical visible disability
cannot be played.
And even though they
have different histories
and oppressions,
both people have
been exploited through media.
And as a people, by the way,
we have absolutely no way
of knowing how many on-air
personalities and performers
have invisible disabilities.
Because there's such a
stigma against things
like mental illness and
chronic pain that to this day,
actors and anchors and
hosts don't feel comfortable
disclosing a disability
that can't be visibly seen.
But if you turn
on your TV today,
you can click to any daytime
show, from CNN to MSNBC,
"Good Morning America," "The
Today Show," "The View,"
"The Talk."
There is not a single visibly
disabled person on television
right now.
So when I got my
big break, it was--
I got invited to be on
"Countdown with Keith
Olbermann."
And when he invited
me on the show,
nobody knew I was disabled.
I went in and I
joked about politics.
I was talking about Saudi
Arabia and Michele Bachmann
and Sarah Palin at the time.
And the fact that I had
disability never came up.
It wasn't part of
the conversation.
So when I went home, I
decided to join Twitter.
Because Keith Olbermann
was my Mr. Miyagi.
And if he tweeted, so would I.
I was like, wax tweet, wax off.
You know.
And so I went on Twitter,
and all of a sudden,
I started having people
guess what was wrong with me.
And they were like,
did you see that girl
on Keith Olbermann's show?
I think she was drunk.
Oh my god, her lip
was so distracting,
I just wanted to yank it up.
Or my favorite one-- she looks
like an honor killing gone
wrong.
And somebody else called
me Gumby-mouthed terrorist
and said they
should pray for me.
So that was my first
experience with trolls.
But on the other
side, as I said,
were the trolls with
good intentions,
those who wanted to save me.
And they would say,
Maysoon, you were so funny.
I loved your TED
Talk I'm so inspired.
It's amazing how
many people tell me
I am inspirational when the
main line of the talk was,
"I am not your inspiration."
People seem to think that
people with disabilities
are here to make them feel
better about themselves.
So these people would say to
me, I love you so much, Maysoon.
You are so funny.
But you need to accept Jesus.
And I was like, I
do accept Jesus.
Because guess what?
Muslims believe that Jesus was
a prophet born to a virgin.
Mind-blowing, I know.
Three candidates
just passed out cold.
And I would then say
to them, but can you
accept that Jesus looks like me?
Because Jesus was
born in Palestine.
And so that's what
I mean by educate.
First, I try to educate.
But if people refuse to be
educated, then I mock them.
And that's the comedian in
me coming back out to play.
So when people insist
that America is not
a place for Muslims,
and you need
to go back to your own country,
I'm like, you mean New Jersey?
Because I know we're
different, but it's actually
part of the United States.
And I they think that there's
a country out there called,
like, Islamland, where
all the Muslims came from.
Because I was doing a show
in Texas, and this woman
came up to me.
And I had told the story about
the drunk doctor in New Jersey.
And she came up to me
and she goes, so when
were you naturalized?
And I was like, well, like,
you know, my first joke,
about, like, I'm
born in New Jersey?
And she's like, I know, I know,
but when were you naturalized?
And I was like, well,
I was born here.
And she's like,
but you're Muslim.
And I was like, yes.
Sit with it.
Just keep sitting with it.
So after I'm done rambling--
because I'm totally rambling,
because it's 12 noon, and
that's what I do-- there's going
to be a Q&A. And you guys
have to think of questions
and participate.
I know it's hard.
But you guys have
to ask me questions.
Then I'll ignore the
questions and I will
talk about whatever I want.
So after I got engaged,
I brought the fiance back
to America.
And my friends, instead of
throwing me a bridal shower,
they threw me an intervention.
Because here's the problem.
I went to Palestine
basically single.
I come back married, right?
And they don't understand
that Arab girls don't date.
We get married.
And if you don't
believe me, look at what
happened to George Clooney.
It's true.
It's totally true.
And so when I walked
into my bridal shower,
Tina met me at the door
holding a piece of paper.
And she was like, Maysoon,
the decisions you are making
are affecting both
of you and us.
And I am here to tell you that
you are a free American woman.
And you do not, I
repeat, you do not
have to have an
arranged marriage.
And I was like,
Tina, I arranged it.
So this whole thing about social
media and Twitter and stuff all
comes full circle to
the fact that I do not
think that if I grew
up with social media,
I would actually ever have
become a stand-up comedian.
By the time that I got
exposed to the fact
that people hate online, and
that that hate can bubble off
into the real world?
I had a woman named Tammy.
Isn't that just the
most sinister name?
Have you ever met
a non-evil Tammy?
Good Tammy, I know
you're out there.
For every dark side,
there's a light, Good Tammy.
I know you're there.
But this woman named Tammy
started stalking me on Twitter.
And she hated my politics.
Because I have very
controversial politics.
I'm here to admit that.
I believe in equality for all,
regardless of faith, race,
ability, orientation, economic
class, and anything else that
could other you.
And people do not dig
that kind of radicalism.
Like, the idea that
everyone should be equal
is just so disgusting, right?
And so Tammy was
really not having
my wanting equality for all.
And she somehow found my
chefugee's cell phone number.
And you may ask yourself
what a chefugee is.
A chefugee is a
refugee who is a chef.
Because the refugee that
I caught and brought
to America now owns a vegan food
truck, so I call him chefugee.
And I never use his
real name because I
don't want people like Tammy
to google him and find me.
But somehow she did.
And she started calling
my house 24 hours a day.
And I had to actually go
and get a restraining order.
And when you're
being cyberstalked,
no one takes you
seriously at all.
And when you're a comedian
that travels the world,
the restraining order will
only cover you in one place.
So any other place
that I publicly
announced that I was going
to be made me vulnerable.
And it became the
reality of my life.
The reality of my life
is, as a Palestinian
who happens to be
Muslim-- because you
can be Christian or atheist
or Buddhist or Mormon.
We're not just one religion.
It's not a monolith.
But as a Muslim woman
that performed uncovered
and uncensored all over
the Middle East, in Doha,
in Beirut, in Jerusalem,
Ramallah, Amman, Cairo,
I had never in my
life been threatened
by a fellow Muslim or a fellow
Arab who identified as such.
And in America, the reality of
my life is on a daily basis,
I get threats from
right-wing extremists
who do not believe
that I have the right
to exist in this country.
And it's interesting to
me that we live in an age
where I grew up with
the same best friends.
They never made fun of me.
The disabled kids that reach
out to me on a daily basis
online now-- because one of
the blessings of the TED Talk
was the fact that people who
never had access to the world
now do.
That means people who
are non-verbal, people
who don't have the ability to go
to settings like this, because
up until recently, buildings
weren't accessible,
they got a whole new
accessibility to the world
through the internet.
So for every troll,
there was another person
who was worth knowing.
For example, I'm
rarely defeated.
And I have this mantra,
and it's Yes, you can can.
Right?
My dad taught me.
It's, yes, you can can.
Means, like, you
can do anything.
And sometimes I get defeated.
And one of the times was when
I was offered a job writing
at the Daily Beast.
And I really wanted to do
it, but I couldn't physically
keep up with the typing.
And if I paid a typist, I
would actually make no money.
So I complained
about it on Twitter.
And this woman named Mary
volunteered to type for me.
And she's been typing for
me for three years straight.
She typed a book.
She typed a screenplay,
every single article
I've ever written for
The Daily Beast and BBC
and anything else
I've ever written for,
and she's never
charged me a dime.
And there's another
thing that I do,
which is I live-tweet
"The Amazing Race."
And I've been doing
this for years.
And I have a
teammate, and our team
is called Team [INAUDIBLE].
It's a long story.
But we race every single season.
And by the end of it,
I feel like I actually
have raced around
the world in a race
that I could never actually do.
And "The Amazing
Race" and reality TV
is the one place
that we actually
see disability reflected
honestly in media.
With "Dancing With the
Stars," "The Bachelorette."
"The Bachelorette" is
my favorite example
of mainstreaming disability.
Because there was a Bachelorette
who was missing a limb.
And she proved that you could
be disabled, vapid, annoying,
and desperate, just like
any other Bachelorette.
And that's the other problem.
The other problem is
on the rare occasion
that television does cast
someone with a disability,
we are rarely seeing
people of color.
And when they do, as I
said, you don't see them
as the lawyer on "Scandal,"
or the best friend
on "The Big Bang Theory," or
a romantic lead in a sitcom.
It's always that
very special episode.
And one of two
things has to happen.
Either they have to be healed,
or they have to scream,
you can't love me
because I'm disabled!
And I just want to scream
back, no, we can't love you
because you're annoying.
Anyway.
So I have a lot of anger.
Because in the
Oppression Olympics,
I would win a gold medal.
I'm Palestinian, I'm Muslim,
I'm disabled, I'm a female,
and I live in New Jersey.
It just doesn't get
worse than that.
OK.
So I'm gonna wrap up
everything that I've
been talking about
with a joke that
has nothing to do with anything,
because I feed off laughter.
And then a really
serious statement
about how you guys can fix this
broken world. 'Cause the world
is busted.
I decided to stop
using the word bitch.
Because bitch is misogynistic.
And it never really
occurred to me,
except I was doing this
panel with Felicity Huffman.
Sorry, I just dropped a name.
I'm palsy.
I drop stuff.
Oops.
And she was like, you know, we
shouldn't use the word bitch,
because it's misogynistic.
But I'm so used to
using it that I needed
to find a replacement word.
So like, I'd love you guys
to join me in replacing bitch
with the following word.
Popple.
It's spelled P-O-P-P-L-E.
And for those of you who
don't know what a Popple is,
it was a stuffed animal
from the '80s that
had the ability to stuff
its head in its butt
and become a ball.
And it works out perfectly as a
replacement for the word bitch.
Because first of
all, like, if I'm
like, why you being
such a Popple?
The person you're yelling
at is like, I don't even
know what she just said.
Am I-- am I insulted?
I kind of-- I don't know.
And then like, what
a basic Popple.
Or you're like, Popple, please!
And what you're saying is, stick
your head in your ass and roll
outta here.
So it's like my
"fetch" or "fleek."
And I would really appreciate if
the Google Empire started using
Popple instead of bitch, OK?
Can I get a witness.
So the world is broken.
But we can fix it.
We can fix it by saying no.
Say no to being
an internet troll.
And if you have kids, say no
to raising an internet troll.
Say no to arming
violence worldwide,
and say no to violence
against women.
It is very, very
disturbing that I
can walk around a war zone
at 2 o'clock in the morning
and feel safer than
I do at 2 o'clock
in the morning on a
US college campus.
Say no to being silenced.
Your voice is your weapon
against inequality.
Use it.
My name is Maysoon Zayid, and
if I can can, you can can.
Thank you, Google.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]
See, this is really good.
People are always
fascinated by the fact
that I can walk in heels.
Or limp in heels, as
I like to call it.
And there's a good
reason for that.
And that's because when my
dad taught me how to walk,
he used to dangle a
dollar bill in front of me
and have me chase it.
And so my inner
stripper is so strong
that I was, like, running
in stilettos at, like, five.
OK, who has a question?
In the back.
AUDIENCE: What happened with
the person-- [INAUDIBLE].
What happened with the person
that made a slur against you
in the car?
MAYSOON ZAYID: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: You gave an example
where someone made a slur--
MAYSOON ZAYID: OK,
so the person who
made the slur
against me in the car
was actually my best friend.
And she is proof that a lot
of people still to this day
do not know that the
R-word is a slur.
And now I'm going to
talk to you about words.
I think that context
actually matters.
And I had the Mothers
Against the R-word
came after me because
I tell that joke.
And the reason I tell that
joke is if you go online and go
look at clips of me,
you'll find 10 to 20 people
in the Comments section
that say she's retarded.
Or retard.
Like, I get called
it all the time.
So I think of it
as a word that I
can use, because I want people
to understand that not only is
that offensive, but
it's sometimes a word
that people don't even realize
they're being offensive.
So when she said it, she didn't
know that it was a bad thing.
You know, I work with
kids in refugee camps.
And often the kids with cerebral
palsy are put with the kids
with the intellectual
disabilities,
because we slur, and we
drag words, and some of us
are non-verbal.
And the assumption is,
if you're non-verbal,
that you don't understand.
And it's a really
big issue in America.
There's 30 states
that don't allow
people with certain
disabilities to get married.
And there's been a
lot of opposition
to this, because with the
creation of technology that
allows the non-verbal community
to now express themselves,
we're able to show people that
these people do have opinions,
and that they do have feelings.
And just because they
can't verbalize it,
doesn't mean they don't
think of those things.
So I don't punish Tina.
But what I do now is I
punish people on Facebook.
So one of the things
that people like to do
is they'll write,
that's fucking retarded,
about something
that's really stupid
and should be criticized.
And I come back, I'm
like, guys, you can't
use the R-word on my page.
And then they'll come right back
and put fucktard or libtard.
And I'm like, OK, guys, the
word tard cannot be used on this
page.
But the crip community, we call
ourselves the crip community.
We use the word cripple.
We don't like the fact that
it's used on news reports
to describe things
that are negative.
We're trying to bring back
like a positive image to it.
Because you have a
lot of associations--
and I'm going off on a tangent,
but I hope it makes sense.
You have a lot of
associations that
are run by parents or people
without the disabilities
speaking for the people
with disabilities.
This happens with CP.
It happens with autism.
And it happens with a lot
of other disabilities.
And there's a myth that
people with disabilities
spend day and night
dreaming of being healed.
And it's just not the truth.
And so there's a lot of
people trying to cure us.
There's a lot of suggestions of
unnecessary, brutal surgeries
that parents that have
no idea-- they just
want to fix their broken kid.
They don't understand that
you can have quality of life,
that having a disability becomes
part of your personality,
like any other aspect
of your personality.
And I've seen parents have
these extensive surgeries
without the child ever
giving permission.
And the kids grow up
and they resent it.
Because they feel like they
were never good enough,
and the parents were
always trying to fix them.
And I think what made me
so confident was my parents
weren't trying to fix me.
They just didn't really care
that I had a disability.
So it was never a big
deal in our family.
I was treated exactly the
same way that my sisters were.
If they had to clean,
I had to clean.
If they went to
bed, I went to bed.
I got no leeway because
of the disability.
And they did things to
help improve my health,
but I never even realized
they were doing it.
Like, they sent me to dancing
school so that I could walk.
They sent me a piano instead
of occupational therapy.
Because I was born in a time
where the ADA didn't exist.
Accessibility didn't exist.
And they just tried their
hardest to mainstream me.
And I lucked out.
And I don't understand why.
Why am I the person who ended up
with the friends whose parents
taught them to be decent?
Why is it that to
this day-- like,
there's a campaign
going on right now,
and it's such a nightmare.
It's called "Just say hi."
And it's by one of
these foundations that
don't know what they're doing.
And they suggested that if
you see a disabled person,
just say hi.
Excuse me, uh, I'm
not a zoo animal.
And-- and so we reacted.
And I was like, first
of all, I'm really busy.
And if you come up to
me while I'm eating
and you just say hi, I'm just
gonna spit and blame the CP.
And then they delved further
and they said, well, you know,
it's because people don't
know how to approach people
with disabilities.
And this is fascinating to
me, that in 2015, people
don't know how to talk
to someone with CP?
Why is that?
I'll tell you why.
Because if you turn
on your TV, there
are no positive
images of disability.
And that is where
children learn, a lot more
than from their parents.
Yes, parents have
dropped the ball
at teaching their kids to be
more accepting, whether it's
of someone who doesn't
believe in Santa,
or someone who has severe burns.
That is a parent's job.
But you and I, we all
know a lot of parents
are not good parents.
Like, that's a total myth.
And I hate on holidays,
when social media is flooded
with stuff like, if you
don't call your mom,
you're an asshole.
Well, maybe they
don't have a mother.
Maybe their mother beat
them their entire lives.
So what do we look at then?
We look at TV.
Why doesn't Sesame Street have
a permanent disabled character?
Why doesn't Dora have
a disabled friend?
Why, when you turn on
daytime talk shows,
a show like "The View" that has
represented every type of woman
you could imagine, including
those with their so
little information they
should never speak in public,
they've never once had a
visibly disabled host-- why?
So if you don't see these
people on television,
and you don't meet these
people in real life,
that's what makes
us a spectacle.
But it's shocking to me
that a foundation that
claims to represent
people with CP
decided to do a campaign with a
bunch of celebrity videos, none
of which included celebrities
with CP, saying, if you see me
on the street, just say hi.
Again, like I'm totally
paranoid about being killed.
It's, like, my big thing, right?
I have no fear.
I've been in war zones.
I've been shot at, but not hit.
That's what counts.
But I'm a touring comic,
and I tour by myself.
So I'm constantly afraid
of being serial-killed.
So if random people just start
popping up and saying hi,
I'm gonna like start
doing jiu-jitsu,
and it's not gonna be pretty.
Next question.
AUDIENCE: Are there
any things that you
find encouraging
about what's happened
since your talk and all
the success with it?
I mean, you mentioned
that TV hasn't progressed.
But are there rays
of hope, in terms
of seeing people with
visible disabilities as just
normal people?
MAYSOON ZAYID: Yeah.
So the downside of
the TED Talk was
I got millions and
millions of hits.
I had the number one
TED Talk of 2014.
I beat all the men.
It's not a competition.
I just won.
[APPLAUSE]
And I was shocked,
because after "Countdown
with Keith Olbermann,"
no one would hire me.
And I heard two things.
One, she's too distracting.
And they're talking
about me shaking.
And two, we hate her politics.
And they're talking
about me wanting equality
for Palestinians.
That's what they hate about
my politics, to be clear.
And-- but the upside
of it was the people
that I told you about.
The people that reached out
to me, like Dominick Evans.
Dominick Evans,
every Saturday night,
does a chat-- not a
chat, but like a thing,
where he does #FilmDis.
Like the word Film and
the beginning of the word
Disability.
And he reached out to me.
And he was like,
hey, Maysoon, we've
been fighting against
able-bodied actors playing
disabled for years now.
And we do this hashtag.
And I joined the group.
And when I joined the
group, a lot of my friends
who are non-disabled, like
Jonas Elrod and Lexi Alexander,
they started
following these guys
and realizing there
are disabled directors.
There are disabled writers.
There are disabled actors.
And a lot of the blowback
I got after the TED Talk
was, she would have no
career if she didn't have CP.
And I thought,
that's so hilarious.
Like, because as if Hollywood
just loves disability so much.
And it was amazing to me
that it didn't translate
into the work I wanted.
But it was also amazing to
me that people literally
have written to me saying,
I was going to kill myself.
I am now not going to.
And that's the thing
that I never expected.
I joke about I never
want to be a role model,
because anyone who
follows me will end up
running around Times Square,
naked, screaming "Jihad!"
But I have people
reaching out to me
that just had a kid
with cerebral palsy, who
were sitting there
mourning the child
that they lost, not realizing
that the child that they had
could have a great life.
And that it wasn't the
end-- it was actually
just the beginning.
I've had people with
cerebral palsy that
are fighting with their
colleges and feeling totally
defeated reach out to me.
And then I get on the phone
with the college, and I'm like,
you don't want me to tweet this.
You do not want
me to tweet this.
Get rid of that gravel path.
And you know, I do yoga.
So there was this theory, and
it's-- like if you google it?
I say that all the time.
You can go on my Twitter
and see how many times
I go, oh, just google it.
I'm not doing your homework.
But if you google this, people
claim that people with CP
start to deteriorate
after the age of 25.
In my case, when I was 27, the
resting position of my hands
was this.
And then I started doing yoga,
and I actually progressed.
So I have people with
CP reach out to me
who have just
thought that this was
the end of the road for them.
I'm like, no, you gotta
look into nutrition,
and you gotta look
into exercise.
And I've been able to give
advice to people in Malaysia,
in Texas, in places that I
would never meet them otherwise.
And what works for me
won't work for everyone.
But if I'm able to get that
one person that just never
had a friend to feel
like they have a friend?
Like that's-- you know, I
said the internet's like "Star
Wars," right?
And there's a dark side.
But the light side
is a lot of people
who never had friends can
actually now find and have
friends.
They find that
community online that
believes in what
they believe in.
And I think that
that's something
that no matter what
else I do in my life,
like win an Oscar--
which I will do.
I just need to get
cast in a movie,
because disabilities win awards.
I think that that's one of
the biggest things that's
affected me, is the
fact that I know
that there are people who had
absolutely no hope, who do now.
Who are living healthier,
more productive lives.
And it's great to have this
team of disabled actors
that are on my side with
wanting the representation
to change in Hollywood.
Because in the intersection
of intersectionality,
disability got run over.
We're the last community
to be represented.
So like, everyone else is
making leaps and bounds,
and we're still not.
And when you realize that you're
not the only one fighting it,
together with our
voices, we were
able to get the Screen
Actors Guild union to partner
and do a workshop that
was all about what's
wrong with disability in
entertainment, this summer.
And we had people from CBS
and from all the big networks
coming in to see.
And understanding
that, like, it's 2015.
We don't need a Just
Say Hi campaign.
We need to be mainstreamed.
Next question.
Two at a time.
He's first.
You're second.
I watched him touch the base.
AUDIENCE: I actually
a meeting at 1:00.
But it was very
interesting watching you.
Thank you.
MAYSOON ZAYID: What, what, what?
AUDIENCE: I had a
meeting at 1:00.
But it was very
interesting watching you.
MAYSOON ZAYID: OK,
thank you so much.
Follow me on maysoon.com.
M-A-Y-S-O-O-N.com.
If you forget,
palsy Palestinian.
Palsy Palestinian.
OK, I think she's in the light.
AUDIENCE: So how do you
think technology can help?
MAYSOON ZAYID: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: How do you
think technology can help?
MAYSOON ZAYID: Technology can
help on every different level.
One of the biggest obstacles
that the disability community
alone is facing is
the fact that we often
are denied the right
to education worldwide.
And I work with disabled
and wounded refugee children
with physical disabilities
that were left out
by the public school system.
And one of our biggest
assets is using technology
so that they can communicate.
It really is a game
changer for people
that are non-verbal, for
people who are missing limbs.
It's so important.
I did something for
Google a couple of years
ago called Conflict
in a Connected World.
And I think that
technology also helps
as a voice of the oppressed.
I've seen such a difference in
the way political events have
been covered in
the past 10 years
than I did in the '90s,
when it was completely
controlled by governments
letting cameras in or not.
And now you have all
these citizen journalists
who are given a voice that we
would never otherwise hear.
And I think that has really
been a game changer for people
who suffer oppression.
Where I've seen
it completely fail
is in battling
violence against women.
Because social media
has become another form
of violence against us.
So I'm not quite
sure how technology
plays into battling that.
I don't think documenting helps.
We saw that when kids--
kids-- got a one-year sentence
for a brutal rape.
So I don't know
how technology can
be used to kind of solve that.
So if you figure it
out, you let me know.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I have two questions.
One's very quick.
The vegan food
truck you mentioned
that the chefugee started?
What is that?
MAYSOON ZAYID: It's
called Falafull.
It's based in Hoboken
and Jersey City.
And it's really
interesting, because one
of the things that I found
out was that sugar, chemicals,
caffeine, and meat,
meat products,
made my cerebral
palsy more severe.
They made me spaz more.
So like when Kanye's like, hold
me back, I'm 'bout to spaz?
If I ate a cheeseburger,
I was like, I'm spazzing!
So I decided to try vegan,
and it cut down my spasticity
by, I would say, about 60%.
And it completely changed my
digestion, the way I breathe,
and it just really helped.
Problem is, I'm
addicted to cheese.
So I'm constantly falling
off the vegan wagon.
I just had some
cheddar Sun Chips.
And I was like, I
need sour cream!
And like-- I just, I'm
a failed wannabe vegan.
And so my husband started
a vegan food truck
because I don't allow
any meat in the house.
And he's basically a vegan chef.
It's really cool.
And I think he's really
interesting, and I never,
ever, ever talk about him.
Because I never wanted
people to think that marriage
was an accomplishment,
because it's not.
And I do not recommend it.
But he's a fascinating story.
Because this is a dude who--
all five of his brothers
have been shot.
All five have survived.
And he and all five
of his brothers
have been political prisoners
at some point in his life.
And when he lived
in Bethlehem, he
had absolutely no chance of
pursuing any sort of dream.
So when he came to America,
I was like, you're free.
You can do anything.
What's your dream?
And he said, I want to
work in a supermarket.
And I said, no, that
is not your dream.
And then he came up with
the vegan food truck,
and now he's a business owner.
And you know, he
bought me this ring
to replace the one I bought.
And you know, the American
dream is something
that no one believes
exists anymore,
unless you live in a nightmare.
And then when you
do, you know it does.
So what was the second question?
AUDIENCE: Second
question was, what's
the most annoying thing
about using your phone?
MAYSOON ZAYID: About--
I barely use my phone.
The most annoying thing
about using my phone
is that it falls out
of my hand constantly.
So I just have a series
of shattered BlackBerrys.
And I have to use a BlackBerry,
because I need a keypad.
Because otherwise I'd just
be slapping at a smartphone,
feeling stupid.
And I hate the phone.
I never answer my phone calls.
My voicemail says I never
answer my phone calls.
I don't answer.
And I don't check
my voice messages,
so if you actually want
to talk to me, text me.
And people will go
find me on Twitter.
Like, I'll ignore my phone,
and suddenly my agent
will be tweeting me, like
answer your damn phone.
You know, my mom's not on
social media and that's good.
I would hate that, yeah.
So OK, we have time
for one last question,
and it has to be outlandish.
No pressure.
But one of my nails broke.
I need to get offstage,
because it's snagging my face.
The guy in the New York
Yankees cap in denial
that the Mets are
finally winning!
I'm a lifelong Mets fan,
not a fair-weather friend.
And again, you get
on my social media
and see 10 years of me crying.
AUDIENCE: I'm
actually more of a fan
of Yankees hats than Yankees.
MAYSOON ZAYID: Nice.
That is so strange.
What other hats do you fan?
AUDIENCE: Anything.
I'm a bald guy.
I get sunburned on my head,
so I gotta have a hat.
MAYSOON ZAYID: I
feel your baldness.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Um.
MAYSOON ZAYID: Just
gonna pet myself.
Trying to bring sexy
back to disability.
Is it working?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so
you've traveled a lot.
MAYSOON ZAYID: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And I was
wondering if there
was any place that you've been
that's really doing things
right by you.
MAYSOON ZAYID: Cambridge
High School in Massachusetts.
That's the only place that's
really doing it right.
As far as accessibility,
or as far as equality?
AUDIENCE: I can go with either.
MAYSOON ZAYID: Yeah.
Like, I went to
Luxembourg, and I thought
that place would be perfect.
And it wasn't.
So like, Europe is
failing on equality.
The Middle East is a hot mess.
Texas is a nightmare, but
the food is really good.
There's no place-- there's no
place that's getting it right.
But there are places that are
doing a lot better than we are.
So I just flew back from
Canada, and they are definitely,
definitely more diverse.
Like when I turned on the TV and
started watching TV in Canada,
they're so much more
diverse than we are.
BBC actually forced
there people who
are producers to commit to
putting on more disabled people
or more people of color.
And a lot of people think
that's forced, and it's not.
Like, having something that
reflects reality is not forced.
It's accurate.
But this Cambridge School, they
were the most accessible school
I've ever seen.
They did it totally right.
They had captioning.
So like a lot of people
use auto-captioning.
Auto-captioning is horrible.
It's terrible.
It's like the game of telephone.
It has nothing to do
with what's being said.
So like, Cambridge School
live-captions everything.
It's extremely diverse.
The entire campus
was accessible.
So in that little
microcosm was the best
I've ever seen it done.
But I'll take your question in
a totally different direction
and talk about my favorite
places to do comedy.
So of course I-- you
can sit and relax.
You don't have to stay.
I love, of course, I love doing
comedy in New York, right?
Because this is the
center of the universe.
And I got to perform with Dave
Chappelle and Lewis Black,
and you could only do
that in New York City.
Because I would be a loser
waiting my turn at a club,
and they would walk
in and do comedy.
And then I'd be like, I did
a show with Dave Chappelle!
But I love doing
comedy in Texas.
And they are the most,
like, jubilant, happy, ready
to laugh crowd I have ever seen.
And even though
they're in denial,
Texas is really diverse.
Like, I saw like
fifty shades of brown.
I was like, wow!
And worldwide, I love
doing shows in Beirut.
It's another party city.
But I get to do
comedy in Arabic,
and I love doing
comedy in Arabic.
Because Arabic is
such a great language.
It has, like, all
these different words.
And people are used to
Arabic being shouted on TV.
So they go out there and
do tons of jokes in Arabic
and have it be, like, light
and full of laughter, that's
really, really cool for me.
And the best show that
I ever did in my life
was I got to perform
for Muhammad Ali.
And I got on stage
and I said, I'm
performing for the man who
floats like a butterfly, stings
like a bee, has
Parkinson's, and shakes just
like me, Muhammad Ali!
And so that was my favorite,
favorite performance.
But as I wrap up and let
you go back to your work,
I'll tell you about my
favorite celebrity meeting.
So, I love Dave Matthews.
I had seen him 103
times in concert.
And from the age of 14, I
used to say to my friends,
someday I'm going to
meet Dave Matthews.
We're going to chat,
become friends.
He's going to give
me his number.
I'm gonna tell him
all about Palestine.
And so I got cast in this
movie with Adam Sandler called,
"You Don't Mess with the Zohan."
And I walk on set, and it's
like a comedy dream come true.
I walk on set and it's
Chris Rock, Dana Carvey,
Kevin Nealon, Kevin James,
Rob Schneider, Adam Sandler,
and Henry Winkler, the Fonz.
And I'm like, oh my god!
I've obviously died and
gone to comedy heaven.
And I was trying so hard
to be cool, and failing.
And I had this laptop bag
that said Dave Matthews.
And Adam Sandler says to me,
oh, you like Dave Matthews?
He's in the movie.
And I was like, haha, funny man.
So I go and I get my
makeup done to go on set.
And this is like
$100 million movie.
So if you're late, you
make anything late,
you're losing like
thousands of dollars.
And I walk out on set in full
makeup and I see Dave Matthews.
And so Adam Sandler
comes to introduce me,
and I'm like, oh my god.
I can't believe this
is actually happening.
And so I was so
happy, because I had
this beautiful makeup and this
amazing outfit from wardrobe.
And I looked great, like
to meet Dave Matthews.
And I turned around and I went--
and I started ugly crying.
And like, the snot
was meeting the drool,
and it was all going down.
And the makeup people
came running up to me,
because I'm supposed
to go on set,
and I'm crying off my face.
And I started like ranting.
And I was like, and then
when I went to the prom,
and nobody would
dance with me, I
was just like--
(SINGING) Crash into me.
And then I was listening to "Red
Rocks," and there was a war.
And I was like--
(SINGING) Crash.
And I was crying.
And then the makeup
woman came up to me.
And Dave put his arm
around me and I crumpled.
And then I came to, and
they put me in time out.
And I was driving home that
night, and I was like, oh!
I carried a watermelon.
And then I came
back the next day,
and I didn't know he
was going to be on set.
And as I was
walking across set--
there's like 100
witnesses, because nobody
would believe this story
otherwise-- he sang my name.
We became friends,
he gave me his number
and we talked about Palestine.
So dreams can can come true.
Thank you again, Google.
I'm Maysoon Zayid.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
Ready?
One--
[LAUGHTER]